no power means no traffic lights
load shedding is killing the response
time of emergency services and with
power plants buckling under the demand
are we going to be stuck with this it's
worse than ever before it really is life
or life
Healthcare treatment from emergency
response to hospital care we got caught
to a hospital where the generator
stopped working and then it was 18
paramedics and nine ICU ventilated
patients and so it was two paramedics
per
patient and then
nine of us we had to ventilate them
manually for four hours
and so their generators were fixed
from hospitals to homes
85 year old Jeanette matlango relies on
an oxygen concentrator to help her
breathe
she's waiting for the inevitable
at the moment
it is still okay but after
hour two three hours then it starts to
to go down
rotational power Cuts mean this is her
second four hour window today with no
breathing support
and her backup oxygen tank is empty
the long hours with no power have made
it too expensive to refill
when I look at my mom
is she's quiet and expecting this
I can't say anything
but myself I'm scared
me I'm scared to read I don't like this
the infrastructure collapse has left
families mourning their loved ones with
unanswered questions like this mother we
met adaso at her funeral home they told
me that my baby passed on when I asked
what's wrong they said lack of oxygen
but she was an oxygen machine when I
left her they say her lungs are shutting
down they say her brain is not
functioning well so I don't have actual
answers what happened
only around 10 of South Africa's public
hospitals have been recorded as having
consistent power supply
and when people die backup power is
needed to preserve their bodies for
burial a luxury for many mortuaries we
have to move the bodies maybe
um file another funeral home that can
store the body for us for a couple of
days but I mean you also don't want
families to come here and find the
people smelling and things like that
back at Jeanette's house it's a painful
waiting game with the highest of stakes
and the hanging fear that every breath
could be her lost
Sky News Johannesburg